There are places in the multiverse that human
beings were never meant to find.
Worlds populated with swarms of crawling spiders,
isolated dimensional prisons where faceless
corpses mimic the living, and realms bathed
in the purest darkness where a glimmer of
light may reveal more than what a visitor
might ever want to see.
These places serve to remind us that every
one of us is, before any other essential quality
of our collective experience, alone.
Every human mind is an isolated incident,
struggling to make sense of every environment
while hoping to find common ground with the
other people in our lives.
We strive to understand others and be understood,
but sadly it is often the case that we must
interact with fellow human beings whose motivations
seem alien to us.
All too frequently, we are surrounded by people
we cannot relate to, in situations we have
little control over, and even if we make attempts
to articulate ourselves, there will always
be an insurmountable gulf between the limits
of our experience and others.
As far as each of us knows, we are the only
free-willed individuals in the cosmos, and
even the nature of that free will is deeply
in question.
When many of us become overwhelmed by these
bigger questions and are forced to confront
our inherent loneliness, there is an instinct
to turn to unfeeling things for answers.
Surely, the vast expanse of creation that
made us must have done so for a reason?
Most who ask that question spend their entire
lives waiting for confirmation of that reason.
They reach out for something or somewhere
that they are meant to be.
It is only the vanishing rare few that find
it - an unmistakable answer in an unspeakable
place.
A terrifying vista of madness that all but
screams:
You will never belong.
SCP-507 - the reluctant dimension hopper - has
found himself in places like these more times
than he is able to count.
He has seen the spiders, the room of corpses
that mimic human activity, and has peered
through the darkness assisted by a flashlight
and seen only the smiling face of a humanoid
monster.
There are dozens more frightening and unsettling
universes that SCP-507 has encountered, and
all known instances have been archived in
document SCP-507-3B.
Any one of the innumerable horrors that this
otherwise ordinary human male has endured
would send a shiver down the spine of the
best of us, but unfortunately, this is little
comfort to SCP-507.
Facing down the madness of the abyss and returning
intact starts to become less triumphant when
it is a weekly, sometimes daily occurrence.
The dimension hopper can barely have a moment
of peace in this life, as his irregular shifts
into different realities occur without any
warning, and all the research that the Foundation
has done on SCP-507 seems to indicate that
there will never be an end to these trips
into the infinite.
But no end does not necessarily imply the
lack of a beginning.
The tragic existence of SCP-507 could not
have started without a cause, and part of
the Foundation’s goal in containing SCP-507
is to discern an explanation for the humanoid’s
signature unstable mode of interdimensional
travel.
So far, the experiments have raised one burning
question after another, with SCP-507 himself
having difficulty recounting some of the stranger
aspects of the dimensions he hops into and,
in a grander sense, what it might all mean.
But the Foundation has no choice but to listen
intently to SCP-507 and take notes on everything
he says in regards to his condition.
After all, the phenomena of leaping to other
worlds primarily affect the dimension hopper
himself and can really only be understood
through a thorough understanding of the subject.
Over the course of many interviews with SCP-507,
the research team has pieced together what
they believe might be the definitive history
of the reluctant dimension hopper: from his
native reality to the flux of ever-changing
hellscapes that occupies his current days.
While it is impossible to verify, due to the
imperfect nature of memory and the countless
traumas suffered by SCP-507, the Foundation
believes that this record can be used as a
case study for further investigation into
the multiverse itself.
On a less practical level, the interviews
can help the Foundation to improve containment
for SCP-507 and make sure that his existence
is as lacking in unnecessary suffering as
possible.
We’re going back to the beginning: to the
earliest dimensional hops that SCP-507 can
remember in detail.
Considering the persistent nature of SCP-507’s
anomalous capabilities, it was hardly surprising
for the Foundation to learn that the humanoid
did not have a conventional childhood.
507 has never made any mention of identifiable
biological parents, nor of any grade school
educational facility - public or private.
In the absence of these markers of normalcy,
SCP-507 describes spending an indeterminate
amount of his formative years in a fantastical
realm known as Liminora.
Though it has apparently been decades since
SCP-507 had hopped into Liminora, he was able
to describe the dimension in great detail.
A grassy plain overrun with red, honeycombed
standing stones that seemed to sing with thousands
of beautiful voices as the wind blew through
them.
The skies of Liminora were colored a velvety
bluish-purple which never got any dimmer than
a commercial nightlight.
There were shallow streams of spring water
that seemed to run in all directions regardless
of elevation.
There were also dangers in Liminora: flocks
of swooping birds which SCP-507 described
as having the appearance of skinless vultures.
These vultures would often attempt to capture
SCP-507 and bring him to a location known
as The Dawn Well.
As one might expect, 507 was never actually
apprehended by the creatures, but insists
that these were more than ordinary birds of
prey.
Vultures don’t hunt for live human children,
being scavengers, after all.
It has also been made clear that 507 was the
only human of any sort in Liminora.
This has led the researchers to conclude that
he most likely wasn’t born in that reality,
and had previously hopped there from a dimension
of origin that remains inaccessible due to
his lack of memories during infancy.
The dimension hopper claims that his best
friend “Finniker'' always protected him
from these avian threats.
Finniker was another creature native to Liminora
who resembled an anomalous crustacean the
size of a large dog, covered in what SCP-507
believed to be a coat of tufted brown fur.
When fending off the vultures, Finniker carried
a heavy cudgel in one of his claws.
The blunt instrument was said to be carved
from the same material as the musical standing
stones.
Additionally, 507 has remarked that the inside
of Finniker’s shell was mostly hollow and
could be used as a shelter and resting place
for the young dimension hopper as long as
he had the continued friendship of the creature.
Many researchers who have taken statements
from SCP-507 regarding Liminora have reflexively
come to view the unconfirmed dimension and
507’s experiences therein as the product
of a wild imagination made more vivid due
to a traumatic upbringing.
On the other hand, SCP-507 insists that Liminora
is not a psychological coping mechanism and
is, in fact, just as real as all of the other
dimensions he has hopped into.
It’s difficult to dismiss his account entirely,
as no matter how many times SCP-507 is asked
about Liminora and how far apart the interviews
are, the details of the account never seem
to deviate from what had been previously established.
During his time in Liminora, which may have
spanned more than a year, 507 has stated that
he was the happiest he had ever been.
Whenever he wasn’t avoiding the vultures
of the Well of Dawn: 507 passed time by listening
to the music from the standing stones, surfing
the erratic currents of the shallow streams,
and learning rudimentary carving techniques
with Finniker.
In some ways, Liminora was paradise for a
child.
There was no homework or chores, and whenever
it was safe, he could play outside as much
as he wanted.
It wasn’t until one terrible night that
everything about his isolated existence changed
for the worst.
While falling asleep inside Finniker’s shell,
SCP-507 experienced a random dimensional shift
to a deep and forbidding forest.
At first, he thought this new reality was
a dream, as it was abnormally dark and misty,
nothing like Liminora.
Then he saw them: the so-called mammal-men.
SCP-507 remembered their chattering teeth
- long and orange, like beaver’s teeth - as
well as the leathery pale skin that covered
their misshapen bodies.
The mammal-men roared and hissed, making unnatural
noises as they chewed into the trees.
The sound of it all was very distressing for
young SCP-507 who began to flee from the strange
humanoids into the nearby bushes.
He cried out for Finniker, hoping that his
friend would arrive and protect him, but it
didn’t happen.
And try as he might, it seemed as though he
couldn’t wake up from this nightmare.
It wasn’t a nightmare at all, in fact.
But a true dimensional shift from which there
could be no easy return.
Terrified for reasons beyond his comprehension,
the young dimensional hopper continued to
cry out for his only friend.
There was a sudden crack, and a loud whoosh
as one of the great trees of the forest came
toppling down in his direction.
SCP-507 braced himself for the inevitable
impact… but it never came.
He was in what appeared to be a city now,
and it was the middle of the day.
Crowds of human beings surrounded him, and
the sounds of automobiles and phone calls
drowned his mind in the cacophony.
It was a total sensory overload compared to
Liminora, and being exposed to it after having
such a harrowing experience in the forest
dimension caused SCP-507 to break down into
tears.
He continued to weep and call out for Finniker,
but his crustacean friend was several worlds
away now.
When the authorities eventually arrive, given
a call about a lost child, SCP-507 was brought
to the nearby police station.
The officers tried to ask SCP-507 questions,
presumably about where his parents were or
where his home was, but 507 recalls being
unable to understand the language they were
speaking, and thus there was no hope of communication.
The adults seemed equally frustrated, and
tried speaking to the child in a number of
different languages.
Eventually, when no parent or guardian appeared
to claim the child, it was determined that
SCP-507 would be placed in foster care.
From there, SCP-507 was given to a family
that soon became his legal guardians.
He was homeschooled on many of the basic subjects
of science and math and learned the English
language through constant tutoring.
While his new parents and siblings were willing
to entertain his stories of Liminora and Finniker,
they believed that it was little more than
the fantasy of an imaginary friend.
Throughout the rest of his youth, SCP-507
experienced no unusual dimension-hopping,
and began to live a relatively normal and
unremarkable life.
At a certain point, he even began to believe
that Liminora never existed.
None of the other children he knew had ever
experienced something like it, a fact that
they would constantly remind him of in their
ruthless teasing.
Even so, SCP-507 entered his teen years as
a shockingly normal individual given the circumstances.
While the Foundation has never been able to
verify the names and identities of his foster
family members, mostly because SCP-507 has
been reluctant to divulge any related information
- his seeming loyalty to keeping the people
who raised him anonymously is proof enough
that this chapter of his life was not fabricated.
According to SCP-507’s testimony, the involuntary
shifting began to reoccur not long after he
had gone through puberty.
The sudden disappearances worried his family,
and many times they believed that he had attempted
to run away from home.
This also had an impact on his social and
educational development, as maintaining both
friendships and good grades in high school
were difficult when he could disappear for
days and weeks at a time.
The vast majority of these dimensional leaps
are uneventful beyond the strain they put
on SCP-507’s efforts at a normal life, but
one, in particular, has left a lasting impact
on 507.
It was during a Halloween block party in his
senior year when SCP-507 shifted away during
an attempt to refill his punch.
He blinked in shock to find himself in Liminora
once more.
But it was not as he had left it.
The sky was a deep shade of maroon and cracked
like a glass surface.
From these cracks spilled sand-like rain onto
the now desolate plains and dried-up rivers.
The standing stones were mostly broken, and
there was no wind to conduct them into their
song.
The teenage 507 wandered around this ruined
Liminora in disbelief.
The fantastical place he remembered had been
real for his entire life, but now it was dead.
If that wasn’t traumatizing enough, nothing
could prepare him for what awaited at the
Well of Dawn.
Near that strange pit of emanated sunlight
was the rotted, sun-bleached shell of a massive
crustacean.
Finniker.
507 barely had time to take in the sight of
his long-lost friend before he was returned
to the roof of the halloween party.
That was the last time he ever saw the world
of Liminora, but it was far, far, from the
most horrific sights that the multiverse would
have to offer.
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go check out “SCP-507 - Reluctant Dimension
Hopper” and “Can SCP-096 Chase Its Victims
Across The Multiverse?”
for more interdimensional adventures from
SCP-507!